My name is Dana Abdul Jawad, I'm an Android
course manager at Udacity.
I'm going to talk to you about The Android
application development program
in our partnership with one million arab coders
initiative.
This program aims to teach students the basic
skills and expertise
needed in the field of Android Application
Development.
In this program we start with the students
from scratch
whether in android programming or programming
as a whole.
the program kicks off with teaching students
how to build interfaces
then we move to teaching them how to make
interfaces more interactive
The language we use is Java, which is one
of
the most popular programing languages.
After finishing the program students will
aquire the sklls and expertise needed
to independently develop themselves in the
android app development field.
As for the job opportunities there are many.
You can work for a specialized company in
building android apps
with the most famous example being google
since
it's the source of the android system itself
Lastly, android developers could work as freelancers
without being full time employees at any company
as they can develop apps upon request from
clients whether individuals or companies
I would like to encourage everyone to apply
for this program
which was designed to start with the applicants
from
scratch in the fields of android development
and programming
There's no previous level of expertise required.